all right mariah
mariah where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from l.a
los angeles south central to be exact
and tell me about your family growing up
mom and dad um i really don't have no
family i was foster care runaway youth
you know you ran away what age yeah um
well i never met my family ever so
my mom or my dad
um i was in foster care since i was like
two years old and i started to run away
when i was like nine
wow
how was the foster system for you
couldn't do it
what kind of stuff is going on
um i just i don't like authority i guess
and like i i couldn't have nobody
telling me what to do because i didn't i
feel like they didn't raise me so i
raised myself i used to run away so much
no abuse or anything like that um yeah i
went through abuse
being in the streets trying to raise
myself you know like
abuse
whether
with
was drugs or prostitution or whatever
you know
it just came hand-in-hand i guess
so you started working the streets at
what age
um 13 13
yeah how'd that happen
for one of these guys that i was messing
with
yeah yeah how far did you go in school
seventh grade second grade
and even
so seventh grade is what age
about 13. mm-hmm yeah
so you uh you've been working the
streets ever since
yeah and how old are you now i'm 23 23.
do you have a pet now or a year on your
own
honestly i haven't like
i'm like i said i'm pregnant so i
haven't really
been like you know i've been trying to
relax but
i've never had a pimp other than the guy
that i said i started for but he wasn't
a
pimp so you're currently working on
figaro street
yeah
are there other streets you work as well
um i used to work long beach boulevard
yeah that was it really an internet
what's your impression of doing this
kind of work i mean does it depress you
is it okay are you strong enough to deal
with it um
when it's like all going good you know
it's like it's all good you know like
it'd be cool like i guess but when you
really sit back and think about it like
of course not you know
especially how like you know kind of
like got jinxed into it not jinxed into
it but you know bribed into it or
whatever like
i guess you could say manipulated forced
into it yeah yeah
it's not something you would have chosen
for your career you've been doing it now
for
for a while now for quite a while
on and off but
how old do you know 23 23.
do you have kids
pregnant oh you're pregnant yeah and
who's the father
to be honest i got raped by a trick in
bakersfield
so you don't know it's is that that
probably won't be
yeah he won't be in the child's life
yeah
how far along are you
i'm due next month on 26th really
and you're gonna try to raise the child
yeah yeah
i was a foster child so i don't really
believe in abortion so you know
like i
everybody deserve a chance
and where do you stay now do you have a
apartment or you just go motel the motel
yeah
motel hotel yeah so you kind of have to
work every day to make
yeah basically
or
finesse somebody or something like you
know like
work the ways of
you know yeah
you're friends
yeah you do
i feel
girls who work the streets with you
um i try not to too much you know
socialize as they say yeah socializing
because like i don't have a pimp you
know and they be trying to get it you
know they trying to get me tonight
tell me about some of the tell me what
happens on some some of the dates you
guys pick you up i mean do they you get
guys asking you to do it without a
condom or oh absolutely yeah they come
with the most
outrageous things i ain't gonna lie like
you know it'd be kind of wild like
not like i'm not saying i'm dirty or
nothing but sometimes my mind it crossed
my mind like you know like damn why
would you want to like you know have
intercourse with a female you don't even
know like unless there's something wrong
with you or something you know like and
you just don't care or something but
like you know like
i don't know i guess since it wasn't
always something that i would i feel
like i would go for like you know
like you know like it says in the bible
you know sex marriage before sex or
whatever i used to look at it like that
but
i don't know what happened
are most of your tricks uh married you
think
mm-hmm yeah or they got a girlfriend or
a big mama or
somebody some
and i don't even say that because they
always be like man you got the condom
rapper
do you got the economy you make sure you
got the condom record
i got you
oh they don't want you leaving the
rapper in the car yeah oh my god
so you do a lot of car dates
off yeah for sure yeah
you had bad experiences out there
bad
oh yeah
when i first
like you know i when i first started
working
i was pretty green for a cool minute it
took me a minute to like really start
understanding you know
like they got they got all the tricks
and all the trades and all the moves to
try to
you know try to play you out of whatever
it is you know like try to you got to
make them realize like
they trick and that's they place and
you know like if you stay on your ground
i guess like i got i got into a few
fights with some tricks cause they're
trying to rob you yeah
i got beat up pretty bad one time
and they they locked me in a room
luckily i guess like i was yelling out
enough for the person the manager the
room manager like to call the police
and they finally left out of the room
but i got beat up pretty bad
and robbed a couple times
and you're you're you probably feel like
you're
you have no other options right now
especially if you're going to be
supporting a child
in a seventh grade education you
probably can't really
and i don't have no job experience i've
never had a job like you know like
that's all you've ever done i was a
foster kid so i it's hard for me to get
my id it's all type of like little like
you know like
roadblocks
that make it harder
is this just survival
for the most part right now yeah like
now that you know my i'm pregnant and
stuff yeah
yeah yeah for sure it's you're gonna be
survival once your baby comes right
and like i said i've never had a job or
anything so i really don't even know
where else like going legit i've never
even like really thought about that it's
kind of i run from that more than
anything because i really don't know how
that could turn out
it's so hard to get there do you see how
dangerous and crazy this lifestyle is
though yeah
you're aware of
that what you're doing is is pretty
crazy
if i could take it back i ain't gonna
say i would because it's made me who i
am now but you know like
changed a few things yeah
a lot of things
did you have dreams of doing something
absolutely i used to want to be a
pediatrician
that went out the window so fast
once i started running away from
my places my group homes and my
placements my foster homes and drugs
came in the picture so yeah
so drugs are part of your life
yeah a little bit
so crystal meth i'm battling crystal
methamosa yeah
do you have any any people in your life
that you would you would consider a
parent not really nobody
i got foster parents but no
like one set of foster parents that i
kind of keep
well i kind of got more closer to now
that i'm pregnant rather than at any
time like you know i thought they kind
of turned their backs on me like a long
time ago but
i guess i was wrong a little bit but i
still i'm still like in the doubt with
them too but
yeah but the people on the streets are
probably more your family than anyone
else it sounds like
i don't know who to choose
yeah trust is a big thing isn't it yeah
especially you know
that's the world like this well i'm not
gonna say the world is messed up but you
know like just doing the stuff we do
like living the lifestyle we live
with all that comes like negativity so
you know yeah you're surrounded by
hustlers and
like everyone around you is up to no
good you're right
that's going to wear on you after a
while right yeah
and you get depressed sometimes
you get depressed
a lot of times especially being pregnant
now like this is like the worst time of
my life
is this your lowest point
yeah thank you
are you scared
yeah you must be
what are you scared of most losing the
baby
yeah like just
having her grope with no family like i
did i guess
but it's so hard like it's not easy you
know
i've been doing what i've what i've been
doing for so long it's like
i don't know it's hard
it's hard like and then
the whole how it came about you know
like
my little situation from getting
pregnant
was is the hardest for me like how i'm
was explaining to her when she grow
older
but
i guess i could say that for them
the tattoo on your on your brow
tell me about the tattoo on your eyebrow
crazy thing you ask about
this is a guy
one of your pants huh one of your pimps
well
he was i thought he was my boyfriend
he ended up playing me and then
i don't
know i kind of like
he used to like make it seem like
that's what made him happy i guess
and i've seen our like relationship
going through like a break-in
and so like
he's just i used to always hear him talk
with his homie like you know about how
how happy times he had when he used to
have his little [ __ ] and [ __ ] so
i guess like you know like i took it
upon myself
well we got into altercation and i took
it upon myself
when the police he went to jail and he
went back to
out of state
and i guess like when he went to jail i
missed him so much i guess like i took
it upon myself
to get him back out here in only way
like
and in my mind at the time i could get
him back out here was hey
go to fig
it only took me one date
and i got him back out here i paid for
his ticket back out here
and after that all hell just nothing was
ever
what is what it was said or like i don't
know
it took me a minute to like really learn
like his manipulative ways and stuff you
know like it took me a really long time
i'm still
kind of
i'm still learning right now like trying
to like break that habit myself right
now like you know
with the same person right now like
and it's hard
it's hard to shake a bad habit
yeah especially when you don't know
where else or nothing else to do where
else to go
did you have any examples growing up of
loving relationships
did you ever see any loving
relationships when you were growing up
no no examples of that every
relationship i've been in i like
it's been like a domestic violence or
whatever like
i don't even call it a relationship just
abuse it yeah
i don't even have relationships
yeah well it's hard it's hard having a
relationship when you're doing this kind
of work too yeah it is
because either they want you to
fully
be with them and do what they say and
quit or they want you to
give you their give you give them your
all and just like break yourself for
them or something like you know and it's
it's never like in the middle fair or
nothing like that you know i don't think
that's that word exists like in this
type of life do you get asked to do
things sexually that you're not
comfortable with doing
before yeah but i kind of like i just
made myself as like open-minded as
possible
like i just looked at it like okay
the more extreme the more money
just like that like you guys you got to
survive so
yeah the more extreme the more money
you have any regrets in your life
i don't regret anything i've done ever
in my life because like i said it made
me who i am today
but if i could have changed anything
yeah i would have changed a lot of stuff
probably some some good parents
well that if you could have if i could
have yeah absolutely but i'm saying like
the decisions i made like you know wise
what's the most important thing you've
learned in your life
never go against yourself and what you
feel like is right
for anybody
like you gotta love yourself before you
could love anybody else
because in the end it's gonna be you
and people give you what you you know
how you treat how you put yourself out
there is what people
look at you for
all right all right thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck with with
your baby and everything else
thank you very much
you